10 people who were killed in an
apparently racist attack on saturday
police have described the 18 year old
suspect in the supermarket shooting
peyton gendron as demented
11 of the 13 people who were shot in the
attack were black
the queen has made a surprise appearance
at paddington station in west london
today to see the new elizabeth line
which was previously known as crossrail
her majesty carried out the rare public
engagement having missed the state
opening of parliament last week because
of mobility issues
well now it's been the last bastion of
defence in mariupol after weeks of
russian siege and bombardment and today
more than 260 ukrainian soldiers have
been evacuated from the azov style steel
plant in the ruined city ukrainian
officials said the soldiers are heroes
who changed the course of the war after
they kept russian forces at bay for 82
days in the labyrinth of bunkers and
tunnels below the steel works
well russia is continuing its push in
eastern ukraine there have been heavy
bombardments across the donbass region
in the last 24 hours significant
fighting is currently taking place in
luhansk and donetsk but strong
resistance from ukrainian troops is
slowing russia's progress once again
and as you've been hearing overnight
more than 260 ukrainian soldiers left
the azov style steel works in mariupol
after an 82-day battle
the evacuation of soldiers has
effectively given russia control of that
port city
the soldiers were taken in buses to
russian controlled areas the wounded
were taken to a hospital in the city of
novo azovsk while more than 200 are
believed to have been taken to the town
of olenivka
meanwhile ukrainian troops have reached
the russian border after successfully
pushing russian forces away from the
country's second city of kharkiv
well that sets the scene then for your
questions right now as we've been
telling you our security and defense
analyst professor michael clark is here
to go through them and uh some of the
first questions michael of course
concern the situation in mario paul
let's start with jt's question and jt
says russia now effectively has control
of marijuana as we've been seeing on the
map including the azov style steel plant
how does this impact the war
strategically
what change does it make well it gives
the russians a chance to release some of
the troops that they've been using
around the other style steel works um in
truth they've had mario pole now for a
few weeks but this avostar issue was is
very bad for them symbolically and they
tied up troops trying to do something
about it it would have been more
sensible to be honest for the russians
to have allowed this humanitarian
gesture weeks ago to take it off the
board instead of which it's done them a
lot of harm in terms of general world
opinion and these troops down in inside
the other style steel works they were
never going to be bombed out because
that was a soviet era complex which was
made with nuclear bomb shelters so they
were never going to bomb them out they
couldn't starve them out because they
obviously had reasonable food stocks and
any commander would have been stupid to
send his own troops down into the
tunnels after them that would have been
a massacre of russian troops so the best
thing they could have done to take it
off the table was to offer them free
passage out and all the rest of it but
they stuck to this you know russian plan
of destroying them in the other style
they didn't succeed so now at the 11th
hour there has been some humanitarian
gesture good for them um it takes it
away from the the battle moves forward
now the russians need all these troops
further north where they are um short of
troops in this big offensive in the
donbass region well let's talk about the
russian bonafides did you say a
humanitarian gesture or is it well uh
this question comes from sharon sharon
asks how can azov fighters safety be
guaranteed in russian controlled areas
of ukraine how can they trust russia
we'll release them in a prisoner
exchange for example how will they treat
those wounded soldiers and in particular
these 260 who've been taken out of
azeroth style i spoke to a member of the
battalion the azo battalion in that
steel works last week and said i
mentioned the whole idea of some kind of
humanitarian deal he said well we know
what the russians think of us how they
term us we don't trust them can we trust
that these soldiers will be put into
safe care the wounded will be treated
and those that aren't will be treated
under the hay convention well i think we
should pay tribute here to the tireless
work of the red cross the international
committee of the red cross and the
united nations they have been talking
for ages secretly or privately with the
russians and the ukrainian government
and the other style uh people and this
has gone on and on and on below the
surface in trying to get something
arranged and these are very brave people
they're on the ground they're in a war
zone un and icrc international community
red cross staff and what they've done is
arranged this with the prisoner exchange
the ukrainians hold quite a lot of
russian prisoners the russians want to
get their prisoners back and that's a
sort of mutual hostage situation so
they're saying you know we will release
your prisoners if you release ours in
good condition that is you know without
any abuse and they these uh ukrainians
they've got to rely on the supervision
i'm guessing of the icrc and the un
staff they will have to look to see that
this exchange is conducted without abuse
on either side on either side i mean
ukrainians have you know have abused
some of their prisoners and we've seen
it not not widely but they have done it
and so we've got to they've got to rely
on these very brave members of the
international community to fix this
courier very carefully choreographed
exchange
i mean do you know what it put me in
mind of you know going way back to the
balkans conflict um srebrenica we saw
that that population the the men and the
young teenagers some been separated put
on coaches under the eyes of the united
nations
and we were told by the serbs they were
going to have safe passage that's right
they didn't have eight thousand eight
thousand were killed and the dutch who
were there at srebrenica they stood but
there was nothing they said there was
nothing they could do because they
thought it was the best outcome and you
know the dutch have been beating
themselves up about that ever since
well uh let's um
ask more about the situation now in
mariupol uh how it's changed and this
muhammad saying and now the soldiers
have been evacuated has ukraine fully
given up the defense of the city well as
you say they pretty much had already it
was just this hold out yeah that's right
i mean mario paul is gone as far as
ukraine is concerned for now
um the ukrainians are under pressure um
around slaviansk and kramatosk
are the two places they've now got to
safeguard and severely
which is now the focus of the battle
further north in the donbass and that
donbass battle is building because the
russians are still bringing in more
forces the russians have still got more
to put into it which they will put into
it because they've only got one
direction in which they can go now which
is more more troops more equipment more
push
so the ukrainians have got to give up on
mario paul however i note that president
zielenski in his cheeky chappie sort of
uh of statesmanship said we of course we
will host the eurovision song contest
next year since we were the winners this
year and we'll host it in mario paul why
not indeed well let's hope so um
continuing with this this is about the
strategy then how does the the fall the
final fall of mario paul how does it
affect things as say from matt uh russia
has taken this land bridge and secured
mariupol can you see a situation where
the russians refocus on this as their
main objective rather than attempting to
take the whole donbass region so they
have that land bridge now from russia
itself all the way through to crimea
they have yeah it's possible they can do
one of the two but not both at the
moment i mean they are seriously short
of troops and i think we may talk about
that a little bit later
um but effectively what they're doing is
taking smaller and smaller cuts at the
donbass this this began in a much more
grand way that they're going to draw a
line it seemed from kharkiv in the north
right through to mario paul and that
line has gone further and further east
they're taking smaller bites after this
big salient where 40 percent of
ukrainian forces are
so in a way they they can
consolidate in the donbass or they can
try to consolidate in the so-called this
land bridge from mariopol to crimea and
they would like it to go past crimea of
course as far as mikaliv and ultimately
odessa but that's looking like a very
far
distant project at the moment so i'd say
they could do it but my guess is they'll
concentrate on donbass because president
putin has said it it's the rationale for
what they want to do to protect the
russian speakers in the donbass is what
they say from ukrainian government
persecution and unless they're seen to
do that in some meaningful way which
really means taking slavians and
kramatorsk
if they take those two cities then the
donbass looks as if it belongs to the
russians that's what they'll need to do
okay well that sets up this next
question from jeremy about uh supposedly
the shape the form of the battle that
may take place there in donbass and the
one that already uh seems was going to
happen uh jeremy ourself the russians
were forced to retreat from the north of
kiev we were told they would regroup to
concentrate on the donbas
analysts predicted large-scale tank
battles on the eastern plains what
actually happened to those that's a very
good question isn't it yeah well there
were tank battles but they weren't the
sort that people thought about i mean
this is not so far away from kursk which
was the greatest tank battle in military
history or the worst tank the second
rule the second world war between german
german tanks and and russian tanks and
that was tank versus tank you know the
the the soviet t-34s against the german
panzers and so on and that that
literally was a sort of a battle of
crusader tanks against each other this
has been a tank battle most of the
equipment that's been lost on both sides
are tanks but it's not tank for tank
it's tank versus aerial systems drones
artillery
anti-tank weapons in the case of
ukrainians and aircraft and so it is a
tank battle but not quite in that cursed
second world war but it was also thought
michael the terrain was different north
of kiev you've got the wooded areas the
marshes this is is it more open plains
and fields well parts really are but
you've also got the donette river and
all its tributaries and lots of lakes so
there's an awful lot of water there and
in general what you've got is the the
russians are by and large on the east of
the donate river and the ukrainians are
on the west and that gives them both
quite good defensive positions but of
course defensive position is no good to
the russians and one of the things in
military psychology is that when units
get into a good defensive position it's
quite hard to get them to move out but
for obvious reasons you can order them
out but they're rather slow to move out
of a good defensive position but my
goodness they're pretty quick to move
away from a vulnerable position i mean
it's
basic human nature so the the so the
river that sort of snakes all the way
through the donbass is a major
determining factor of how this battle
goes it's it is open open-ish country it
is ripe for armored warfare but lots of
other things have got to be right as
well and remember we're still in the
spring the the ground is still soft it
won't be until the summer when the
ground gets hard and dusty that tanks
and armored vehicles can spread out away
from the roads and move forward and if
the russians are still fighting that
sort of battle in the summer
then they won't be doing terribly well
okay well another question about the
battle for the donbass this one from
caroline
who says the war seems to have been a
disaster from the start for russia and
now it seems russia is struggling to
take the donbass region if they fail to
do this do you think that will end the
war so if it ends up in stalemate if the
ukrainians hold out is that it
um mr putin is not going to lose
gracefully um i think we'd be sure about
that if then this ends up in stalemate
for the time being then his only choice
really is to mobilize remember that the
ukrainians are doing so well because
they're fighting for their lives they're
fighting for their survival and they're
fully mobilized their economies is
tanking because they're putting
everything into this war they're they're
giving it everything
in russia this is still a special
military operation and you know you can
go to prison for 15 years for calling it
a war and president putin obviously
doesn't want to mobilize to to declare
mobilization because that would look
like outright failure but unless he he
creates some form of mobilization he
just doesn't have enough troops to go
beyond the stalemate in the donbass now
there's all sorts of quiet mobilization
that seems to be going on in russia
which is causing some kickback
particularly in the in the in the cities
of the east where recruiting officers
are beginning to call people in and tell
them that they're being conscripted they
said well i wasn't conscripted in april
why am i being conscripted outside don't
don't
question it just you know sign the forms
so there's a lot of that going on and
there's a lot of stuff leaking out that
there are fire bomb attacks on some
recruiting officers and some government
buildings for in the eastern cities
we'll see where that goes but
i suppose what i'm saying is that if
this end if this gets to a stalemate in
the summer or early autumn
then i think putin will up the ante both
in terms of his um the way in which he
presents this war with the rest of
europe this will be nato helping the
ukrainians in ways that are completely
unacceptable
and he will have to find more troops and
more forces to put in i mean ultimately
russia is so much bigger than ukraine
that if it mobilizes it can bring this
very inefficient steamroller to bear it
is inefficient it is old and it's very
badly commanded but it is big okay well
we talked a lot about russian
deployments deployment of resources uh
jono's got a question now about the
ukrainians and uh jono asks has ukraine
accepted the temporary loss of casson in
order to prioritize the donbass just
give us a thumbnail sketch of the of the
jeopardy yeah i'm on the way to odessa
yes i mean yeah occursion is um very
important city it's the only city the
russians control and they haven't
controlled it very well because there's
an awful lot of civil disorder there and
a lot of a lot of people are
disappearing i have to say there's a
sort of dark gestapo night has descended
on kirshen which is extremely disturbing
as the stories begin to come out the
ukrainians were moving on it they were
saying a few weeks ago they thought they
might even retake it that was too
optimistic but they're they're they're
they're in the northwest of the city
they've pushed back from mikolayev they
are giving the russians something else
to think about incursion so in a sense
they're fixing russian forces in place
so these forces can't disappear to the
donbass to help putin in his other um uh
uh campaign um they haven't given up on
given up on kersham but but to be honest
this whole war is now concentrating on
what happens in the donbass and both
sides are keeping what i think they feel
are the minimum forces they can live
with in some of the other areas so
cursion is not in my view going to be
liberated anytime soon but the
ukrainians do have an optimistic
scenario that they will get to liberate
it before some other areas okay michael
uh an awful lot to absorb from that much
more to come we're going to take a short
break now and you are watching a special
question and answer program about the
war in ukraine next step we're going to
be asking and addressing why is russia
allowed to blockade grain shipments at
ukraine's points stay with us to find
out
[Music]
this isn't really something that is new
news to many of us because it's
something we've been documenting for a
long time be it dispersable razors
cashmere jumpers or jeans we've
constantly monitored the fact that women
do pay more now when it's a like for
like in men's and women's clothes in
clothing you'd actually expect men to be
paying more as generally the items
contain more materials but it's not as
simple as that and it's not as simple as
just saying well it's a supply and
demand thing which is very much what
drives it we will generally pay more but
there is a risk element that businesses
take on with us as females we tend to
have a lot more to choose from fashion
drives a lot of our decisions so the
businesses say well this is a much
riskier proposition in terms of trying
to get it right
certainly an element of supply and
demand in it if we
will buy it they will put those prices
on it and absolutely that's how the
world goes round i think the fact is
though we probably demand more from our
shopping experience too and i think
there's lots of elements in terms of
that risk factor that businesses have to
take on we're probably more likely to
maybe buy a lot of items online and then
return more but the fact of the matter
is it just doesn't stack up when you are
a female like me like you trying to buy
something that is
pretty much in equal territory a pair of
jeans for instance is a pair of jeans
and if we're paying 20 more it just
doesn't sit well in today's day and age
where consumers are looking for clarity
consistency and authenticity from
businesses i think it might be time for
some of these organizations to realize
that consumers are probably going to
start reacting to that
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back as you know i'm with
professor michael clark who's answering
your questions about the current
situation with the war in ukraine and
michael we've been talking a lot about
the south and the east we're turning now
to the north where clearly i mean you
know the the battle looks like it's been
won but it's not over is it and this
question from nigel
asks how much of a problem is the
belarus military deployment to the
northern border of ukraine will this
impact their progress and could the west
intervene so this is news of very close
russian ally of course to the to the
north of kiev they've they've pushed
their troops up have they they have yes
i mean the second point first no the
west won't intervene uh this won't
provoke western intervention what the
belarusians have done is mobilized or
pushed some of their troops uh in
readiness up to the border um i'm pretty
sure they won't go beyond the border i
mean president lukashenko has been a
study in in what i call the sort of
diplomatic okie cookie in the first of
all he was in he's totally in then he
was completely out then he's halfway in
now he's thinking he's implying he might
be in again in reality if he joins a
failing campaign
then he may be out of office pretty soon
i mean his domestic situation is pretty
shaky he needs putin's support all the
time so i think what this is an attempt
to do is to give the ukrainian something
else to worry about to to put a force
right upon their northwest border that
they have to consider uh as a way and
i'm sure he hopes it will draw ukrainian
forces does it does it tire some of
their forces that could be deployed to
the donbass it ties up yeah it ties up a
screening force but all they need is a
screening force to actually you know
play a delaying role and if you if the
belarusians were you know foolish enough
to go over the border
and lukashenko really threw his lot in
with putin at a time when putin's lot
doesn't look very good
um then the ukrainians could redeploy um
but it won't bring the west in it just
it just gives the ukrainians a
complicating factor but if i was um in
kiev i wouldn't worry too much about
this you don't you'd only be complacent
but a screening force i think will
probably do it okay well let's talk more
about borders and this time the
ukrainian border with russia and of
course some that's victory it seems
around kharkiv would it be wise for
ukraine to advance toward belgarad into
russian territory to interrupt supplies
or would it be too risky militarily as
well as politically and haven't the
ukrainians always said well you've
invaded us we've never had any intention
of invading you so i mean presumably
that would be part of that equation yeah
yeah and ukraine's you know the support
ukraine has around that throughout the
western world in quite a lot of the rest
of the world quite a lot not all is
based on the fact that they are
completely blameless in this they have
no aggressive intent towards russia if
they went over the border then that
would undermine that claim even though
there's a good military case for going
over the border because um if you look
at the um an atlas i was looking at some
motoring atlases of this there is only
one motorway from belgarrod to kharkiv
the
which is what the russians have been
using as their main supply route the
ukrainians now threaten that e105 they
can target it with artillery they can
target it with drones they can use
special forces to target it
unattributably and the the the russians
have now got to go quite a long way east
and there are there are no decent roads
other than the e105 east of of belgrade
so the russians have got real problems
in supplying their forces in the donbass
which they were supplying from belgard
to kharkiv straight down to isim in the
south that was an easy route for them no
longer so the ukrainians are already as
it were playing havoc with russian
communications and
they
or somebody somebody keeps blowing up
the railway line
so
you know they're already achieving what
they what they would like to achieve i'm
sure they'd like to do more of it or
have more of it done um but the fact is
far too politically risky to to move
outside their own borders okay we've got
another question now about russian
intentions and ambitions this one from
matt who asks what does the russian
withdrawal from the kiev region and
bolstering of forces in the east of
ukraine suggest about the ultimate goal
of putin and russia and that is one that
has everyone scratching their heads what
you know what's enough for booty yeah we
don't i mean we don't really know i mean
his ultimate goal is still apparently
the the abolition of ukraine as an
independent state his argument is that
ukraine is not a genuine state
it's a it's a sort of public government
effectively established by the west and
used by western nazis and american
imperialists as a way of of pushing
russia as we're threatening russia
that's to his view and i'm fairly sure
it is his sincere view and so his
ultimate aim is is that he that russia
should simply take over ukrainian
territory as if it were the old soviet
union and ukraine was just one big
region within the old soviet union
however since that hasn't gone very well
and he's now on his third strategy the
first strategy was was grab kiev and
take over the government quickly the
second strategy was a maneuver strategy
grab the cities and take over the
government that way that didn't work so
the third strategy now is well let's go
for some territory in the donbass
that at least is the minimal um
requirement to protect our russian
ethnics and our russian speakers in the
donbass
and it would give him something to
negotiate with
if this ends in a negotiation and then
he can
in his own mind i think he can settle
back he won't be able to settle back but
in his own mind he'll settle back wait
another few years and see where the
situation goes so i think you know his
his immediate aim is get some
negotiating power with territory his
ultimate aim seems to have been what it
always was what about negotiating power
with an an escalation john addresses
this question about chemical weapons uh
if they are deployed by russia in
ukraine does this change the west stance
of not getting involved on the ground uh
to borrow
president obama's victim is this a red
line a red line that would elicit a
response yeah the west is very um
careful now to not to talk about red
lines
in relation to this sort of chemical use
because if you can't enforce them you
shouldn't talk about them if you if you
establish a red line you've got to know
that you can enforce it and you've got
the political power and the political
courage to do so um i think the answer
to this question hasn't changed since
the beginning of the war if the russians
use chemical weapons
we will be even more outraged everything
we are now doing will do more of and
more determinedly
but that still in my view would not
produce a western response on the ground
the so far the the red line that
everyone agrees we should avoid is nato
and russian troops fighting each other
directly and the russians seem to accept
that that's an important red line we
accept it's an important red line so far
that's been the one red line that there
is implicit strong agreement to
and i don't think a use of chemical
would actually cross that line okay
question i suppose about the economy and
ukraine and of course food supplies food
supply is not just
for ukraine but food supplies for the
world this from stephanie we understand
grain shipments can't leave ukraine why
are russia allowed to block airports
surely neutral ships should be allowed
safe passage and protected by the un
from interference i suppose in a way
that brings us back to
not uh getting involved in conflict with
the russian navy yes um
there's 25 million tons of grain tied up
in odessa which is blockaded 25 million
tons normally they shift about 5 million
tons a month so there's five months
worth of grain which has not gone
anywhere so far roughly
and in
at least 14 african countries and four
or five middle eastern countries not in
africa
um who are dependent
on on uh ukrainian grain in particular
about 400 million people
are now seriously in need and it's it's
not only ukrainian grain it's a climate
crisis it's the covid effect it's the
fuel energy price increases which make
all costs higher there's a growing food
crisis this is another twist on that
problem um
one idea
is that
surely the united nations could
establish a sort of a a corridor from
odessa say to constanta in romania which
can also handle bulk grain wouldn't be
that far down the coast to another port
on the black sea in in romania in
constanta and that that actually could
be unsupervised but
you know
should they should they be protected by
the united nations from infinity well
who would do the protecting you know the
un doesn't have doesn't have a navy the
u.n doesn't have any military forces of
its own at all so who do the protecting
i was at a meeting earlier today with
the um
former ambassador to turkey and he just
come back from turkey and he was saying
flying over the boss for us was
interesting he said when you look down
from the aircraft normally both sides of
the bosphorus this is the sea between
the mediterranean and the black sea of
course
controlled by turkey he said normally it
is a maze of ships coming in going out
queuing up to get in queueing up to get
out he said there's almost nothing there
he said the boss for us he said is
almost deserted at the moment because no
one no one will go there and the point
was made that you know a lot of ships
can't get insurance to go into the black
sea so even if they're on innocent
passage they won't they can't get the
insurance that's going to have a
long-term effect michael time to draw
breath again lots more to come you're
watching a special question and answer
programme about the war in ukraine and
next we're going to be asking if turkey
vetoes finland and sweden joining nato
will it weaken the united response of
that military alliance stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark answering your questions about the
war in ukraine right michael coming up
now lots of questions about nato and of
course its expansion with the
applications by sweden and finland this
from alex
saying if turkey wants to veto finland
in sweden joining nato could it weaken
the united response of nato and even if
it is only symbolic in power putin
because we know turkey have voiced
objections yes i mean if sweden and
finland don't get into nato for some
reason now it'd be a huge blow political
blow to nato it would be a massive step
backwards in everything that europe has
stood for since the 24th of february and
it would be absolutely right it would be
a great victory for president putin and
for that reason he is believed to be in
close contact with president erdogan of
turkey uh to talk to him about the
possibilities but um you know there's a
lot we could say about the turkish
position on this and erdogan's own
thinking but essentially yes if this if
this doesn't happen then nato will have
taken quite a backward step well to
address that uh good question now from
ben uh suggesting perhaps the the
removal of turkey could nato remove
turkey and then take in sweden and
finland it seems they'd be more in line
with western values and military
strength i mean because that's the point
isn't it i mean turkey's faced both ways
in terms of nature
got russian weaponry and then supplied
drones to the ukrainian exactly and it's
it's worked with the russians on some
issues and against them on others i mean
erdogan is his own man that's the point
um and he i mean we've sometimes
wondered what have you got to do to get
thrown out of nato how bad do you have
to be how bad an ally do you have to be
but the fact is there's no mechanism for
throwing anybody out the washington
treaty doesn't allow for the expulsion
of any country we used to joke at one
time that we ought to make it like the
premiership that every five years we
should vote on on who has been the the
least nato-esque member and throw them
out and bring in somebody else yeah i
mean i love it but
i mean the french what did they do did
they just prorogue their membership
under the government yeah they left the
tr they left the treaty organization but
but stayed in the treaty that was in
1966 and that was when nato was based in
paris and so the whole of the operation
had to move out to brussels and de
gaulle famously said well of course
we're a member of the north atlantic
treaty but we're not a member of this
organization and it did the french
military immense harm because it meant
that whenever something did come up like
the gulf war in 1991 nobody could work
with them they were completely isolated
because they didn't do the things
they didn't operate in the way that nato
operates and i suppose the other issue
about kicking turkey out if you could
would be well whose orbit would they end
up exactly yeah nobody's going to kick
turkey out and the point is nobody has
ever left nato and remember nato is an
organization that has only ever
responded to people wanting to join it
this idea that that is put around
certainly in in russian circles and with
some uh lines here that you know nato
enlargement nato expansion is the
problem nato has only ever reacted to
other people being desperate to get in
and one of the reasons they're desperate
to get in is because they want the
united states guarantee they want to
know that article 5 an attack on one is
an attack on all includes their their
involvement in this united states-based
guarantee and they want the security of
being inside the camp and now even you
know sweden that's been neutral since
1812 and finland neutral since 1945 even
they now want to come inside the
campaign interesting question from nike
uh from mike on this uh on the issue of
the russian response and that change in
language or was it interesting to get
your take here's the question uh
russia's tone of threats has changed is
this a matter of not wanting to provoke
nato further or could this be a way of
diverting nato's attention to build
forces at the finnish border and this
was the comments yesterday from
president putin said he didn't really
have a problem with finland didn't
sweden join well i think he's trying to
save his dignity here because i mean
this whole crisis he said began because
ukraine was being manipulated by nato
that was constantly threatening russia
by enlarging and expanding and remember
to put myself in his position for a
moment nato has enlarged itself since
1949 nine times nine times it started
off with 12 members it's now got 30.
it's about to get 32. so it's getting
towards three times the size that it was
when it began
and of those nine enlargements six of
them have taken place while president
putin's been in power so he's sat in the
kremlin and he's seen nato's borders
come a thousand miles nearer to moscow
and he thinks in very territorial terms
he's not a very subtle man he's not a
subtle thinker that's what he sees
and so i think he's he was furious about
this idea that finland and sweden join
should join nato it's a massive
political failure on his part strategic
failure i mean it's a massive strategic
failure and i think he's trying to
rescue a bit of his dignity by saying oh
it's no big deal it's a huge deal it's a
major deal okay let's move away from
nato enlargement or not uh jerry's
question number one i suppose a lot of
people are asking but i'm not sure even
if you didn't know how much you're able
to tell us about this uh jerry's
question is this how is the mod
operating its intelligence in ukraine to
be providing daily intel reports on
russian strength advances and setbacks i
mean we do get that daily assessment
from the mod as i say how much of the
intelligence gathering methodology are
you
able to tell us about yeah well i mean
that comes from defense intelligence
which is one of the agencies so our big
agencies are mi5 internal intelligence
mi6 foreign intelligence gchq signals
intelligence and defense intelligence
which is all the intelligence that the
armed forces bring together so that's
our intelligence arm the point is that
our intelligence along with american
intelligence together particularly with
gchq and the national intelligence
agency in the in the states are far and
away the most powerful intelligence
engines in the world there's nobody to
touch them britain and america working
together
are easily the most powerful
intelligence organization on the on the
planet you know working with the
americans
so i mean are we giving the ukrainians
yeah you bet we are uh i i believe
nobody well we heard that from the
americans yes
we found out that you know they're able
to very quickly to get in touch with
ukrainian forces on the ground and and
pinpoint target some of the russian
movements that's right well i mean
they've you know they've had 11 generals
killed in action um and that doesn't
happen until somebody's got i mean
unless the ukrainians are
extraordinarily lucky um they're getting
some quite good information now the
point is that the intelligent i mean i
can talk about this because i'm i'm just
an analyst i'm nobody but um the
intelligence agencies themselves just
keep quiet about it you know if you if
if you if you're doing a good job then
the less you say about it the more
you'll be able to continue to do a good
job so what but what we do know and what
we you know what is in in the public
domain of course is that the aerial
intelligence is still pretty good you've
got nato aircraft flying all the way
around ukrainian airspace all the way
around the edges of ukrainian airspace
all the time looking at what russian
forces are doing and belarusian forces
and that's coming back more or less in
real time so ukraine is getting that
they've got a very good software system
themselves the ukrainians have got
secure communications mainly thanks to
elon musk who's put his styling
satellites above ukraine good job and so
they've got this secure communication
that the russians can't really break
into so the ukrainians got a lot of
advantages and i mean britain never says
never comments on whether we have
special forces in ukraine i don't know
i'd be i'd be very surprised if we
didn't and the whole point about special
forces is not that they go to fight
special forces sas and sbs and so on i
mean they can visit paralyzing violence
on the queen's enemies if they need to
but their job is simply to be
reconnaissance is to exist in any
environment
in small groups or even singly and just
sit there and observe to sit there as a
recon asset and that's the point they
can survive they're completely
self-sufficient you don't have to worry
about them that's what what makes them
special is their ability not to fight
but to survive
and uh i'd be very surprised if there
weren't
some special forces operating on behalf
of the ukrainians i don't know but i'd
be surprised if we didn't fascinating
thoughts michael well let's talk about
what we do know in terms of uk and
others aid to ukraine and dawn asks this
the uk and most of the rest of the world
have provided arms and aid to ukraine in
its billions as the amount of military
equipment provided to ukraine left the
uk
less able to defend itself and other
countries i mean you can't manufacture
this stuff you know you know in a couple
of weeks no that's right the um i mean
the shares in all of the um in all the
big arms companies like british british
aerospace who do a lot of of different
sorts of arms i mean they've basically
absorbed most of the old britain's
british ordnance industry shares in
tyler's for instance who were
manufacturing northern ireland saab who
produced the end law missiles but
manufactured northern ireland same with
javelin and so on so
we gave the ukrainians all of our supply
of end laws which are these anti-tank
the new um
lightweight anti-tank weapon and those
those are end laws on the screen i think
in their cases um the so we gave them
our whole supply then laws um and ben
wallace was asked about this he said
well it doesn't matter you know we'll
get more
but the but the the companies are
ramping up britain has basically given
away
most of its light weapons um so end laws
javelin star streak which is again
another very good anti-aircraft system
much more sophisticated we've given as
many of those i think as we've got and
we are giving some armored vehicles not
not armor uh not not tank armor but
mastiff and maybe jackal vehicles that
we used in afghanistan which are mine
resistant and protect troops so the
battlefield taxis basically for troops
so we're doing that personally um i
don't know why we don't give them our
warrior uh fighting vehicle that's sort
of a very light tank in effect because
we say we're gonna phase the warriors
out in favor of this ajax vehicle as and
when we get it
big issues there but i mean if we're
facing warrior out why don't we give
them warrior they are very effective on
the battlefield but that's that's just
my idea so you know is brittle leaving
itself defenders no
um but it but it means that we're we're
right well the companies are ramping up
the resupply
and this is all costing quite a lot of
money not i think coming out of the
defense budget this i think comes out of
the treasury contingency reserve which
is special circumstance this is a war
happens to be somebody else's war but we
need to take this from national accounts
not
love this on to defense okay well that's
the hardware now let's uh end uh this
section with a question about the
personnel uh sean asks in terms of
personnel how long is the conflict
realistically sustainable for in the
view of both sides now we know we have
an estimate of the russian losses we
don't really know what's going on with
the ukrainians no i mean the russians we
know are fairly confident they've lost
about a third of their force about 60
000 out of 180 190
they can't so they can't keep on doing
that because they're standing army
remember this is not a mobilized country
this is a special military operation
they're stunning armies 280 000
and every year april another 130 000
come in as conscripts and 130 000 leave
so at any given moment that army is in
the process of of rotation and the
conscripts come in they do literally
five or six months training sometimes
seven months training which only leaves
them five months to do anything
soldierly before they are entitled go
again so the russians are actually
pretty short now ukraine has an army of
125 000 smaller but they have reserves
of 900 000 of whom a third 300 000 or
more have fought in the donbass sometime
in the last eight years because of the
situation after 2014. so the ukrainians
can put an army in the field of about
400 000
plus their territorial defense force
which stands at the moment
at about 160 000 and the ukrainians say
we can we can put a million people under
arms and i believe them if this war goes
on that's the the irony of this the
longer this goes on the more the
russians will find themselves out gunned
because of western systems that the
ukrainians are using and outnumbered by
the people that the ukrainians can put
in the field unless the russians
mobilize if they don't mobilize then
they get outgunned and outnumbered well
that's putin's problem what a thought to
end this section on our last section
coming up you're watching a special
question and answer program about the
war in ukraine so next we're asking what
is the most likely way this war will end
now stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
look at that sheet of flake and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
they have breached the road there is
a lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi
these students are defining the
prohibited order and now they're going
to be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
welcome back as you know by now i'm with
professor michael clark and your
questions about the war in ukraine okay
michael let's dive in for this last
section and uh it's uh i suppose looking
at any potential and getting this from
mike saying is it realistic to think
ukraine has the military capability to
restore its pre-2014 borders that's what
we hear all the time from ukraine from
president zielinski
does he have to say that or does he
really think they can do that throw the
russians out of crimea he has to say it
um because he's standing for ukrainian
sovereignty which was breached in 2014
and again twice in 2014 and again in
2022 so yes he has to say it
if there is to be some sort of
negotiation at the end of this i mean i
do think the ukrainians if they if
they're prepared to keep fighting and if
the west is prepared to keep supplying
and if putin doesn't mobilize
sufficiently then i think yes the
ukrainians can push the russians
eventually
back out of their borders but crimea as
you say is a different issue i mean
crimea was only crimea was russian for
200 years it only became ukrainian in
1953 stalin has allocated it to ukraine
and ethnically historically spiritually
most of crimea is actually russian so i
think that the ukrainians they know that
and zielinski must know that if it comes
to some grand negotiation at the end of
the year or next year what i think you
zelinski would like to say is look
leave my territory i will give you we'll
stop worrying about crimea you can keep
crimea because you know basically we
don't want it we'd love it but we can't
you can keep crying and that is my major
huge concession so take it and be
grateful and get out of my territory
everywhere else now can they can they
achieve that militarily not at the
moment
but as i say if they keep fighting if
the west keeps supplying then i think
there's a 50 50 chance that that's where
the ukrainians might be it's certainly
where they think they will be and their
morale is sky high at the moment indeed
okay well if there is a grand
negotiation as you put it michael how
much of a factor would edwina's question
be in this how will the russian
government and putin be held to account
for war crimes against ukraine and we
know the view from paris for instance is
that you know you you don't need to
pursue these issues too hard you have to
give russia some kind of well perhaps
not a victory but some kind of way out
maybe um but war crimes are a very live
issue in this conflict it's the first
conflict that i can think of in my
lifetime or ever for that matter where
war crimes have been on the agenda from
day one and evidence has been
accumulating because of modern
technology and so this evidence is
archived it's not going to go away it'll
be there effectively forever
and there are different forums so
there's the international court of
justice in the u.n which is only state
to state there's the icc the
international criminal court which is
the one everyone looks at which is who's
has jurisdiction just about in ukraine
because ukraine is not part of the icc
but as i said it will accept the
jurisdiction and then there's the
possibility of ad hoc course there was
an ad hoc court for former yugoslavia
there was one for sierra leone uh there
was one for rwanda so they do exist and
gordon brown amongst others who said we
need a special tribunal to deal with
this so it can happen
um the the wheels of international
justice do turn very slowly
but they do turn and they have a long
arm that's the point well i mean for
putin you said this before on these
programs michael if putin is to face
that kind of reckoning then presumably
he has to be out of power let's put
ben's question to you are we seeing the
start of putin's demise with apparent
unrest in russia growing you mentioned
those attacks on recruitment officers
for instance what evidence are we seeing
well not in the in the broader
population we see evidence of some uh
disquiet and some of it's come out on
media actually russian media maybe some
of the mainstream media have started to
discuss um some of the things that are
going wrong
and
one or two commentators are saying we've
got ex-military commentators
interestingly are saying we've got to be
realistic about this um and so there is
that sense of realism is seeping in even
to this very controlled environment but
ultimately the general population may
become more discontented but there's a
rally around the flag effect and that's
what you'd expect putin is still pretty
popular except i think that popularity
is probably
rather fragile maybe rather brittle
we are still saying i'm still saying for
sure that if there is to be a revolt
against putin it's got to come from the
military
and the sloviki who are the security
people so the fsb who uh you know the
old kgb um the the svr and the um gru
the military uh intelligence because
these are the people who have been
blamed they've been asked to do the
impossible and putin is blaming them for
failing to do the impossible and
ultimately their only defense mechanism
will actually be to turn on him now as
and when that happens we don't know
but
unless he can keep suppressing
this um blame culture unless he can find
either somebody else to blame or somehow
get them on board with him for this
failing campaign he's got real problems
real problems okay john uh asks this is
a peace deal in ukraine likely to be
reached soon now that there is a
stalemate well is there a stalemate
there certainly aren't any negotiations
really substantial negotiations taking
place are they there's not there's not a
stalemate yet i mean the fact that the
the the front is not moving forward very
far in the donbass doesn't mean there's
a stalemate it's a bit late it's a bit
like you know i love cricket it's a bit
like watching cricket where for a couple
of hours not very much seems to happen
and then everything happens and you know
that old lenin phrase that you know
nothing happens for decades then decades
happen in days and i still think that's
where we are in this war there's a lot
happening beneath the surface
it's not so it's not a stalemate and to
be honest you know any peace deal will
depend on the ukrainians if they feel
that they want to go into negotiations
then the west will support them i'm
pretty sure we have to
if they don't want to go into peace
negotiations we support that too because
as far as we're concerned they are
fighting for their lives against
unprovoked aggression which is a threat
to the liberal world order that we're
part of so they're fighting for for us
and for that reason we have no choice
really but to stand behind the decisions
that the ukrainian government makes
let's put a full stop to this discussion
where we're nearly out of time through
david's question and what are your
thoughts michael what is the most likely
way this war will end now
or will it end yeah i don't think it
won't end now
it won't end for some time
and when it does end it'll be more
dangerous before it ends i think we're
at a phase now in the war when because
of what i said about mr putin i think
he's actually got to start to mobilize
in some way
the only way he can mobilize politically
is to blame everything on the west and
to say this is not a war about ukraine
this is a war against the west this is
the war to preserve us against western
encroachments which may mean that he
might try to create false flag incidents
to indicate encroachment saying the
baltics or in moldova or wherever so is
that why you say it's more dangerous now
when you know we've seen what's
happening around kiev
you know because people are beginning to
think because putin won't lose
gracefully that's the point and he won't
be pragmatic enough just to withdraw and
try and if he withdraws and tries to
spin it up then his political career is
probably over and so he's only got one
direction he has to keep going forward
which is why i think this war will
become more dangerous before it ends so
this is the time for strong nerves in
the west you know applauding and
cheering on the sidelines with ukraine
um won't get us out of the problem we've
got to be very resolute and we've got to
keep our nerve
okay michael thank you very much indeed
once again i mean that really is
so much food for thought so much to
digest thank you very much dee for
sharing your expertise with us professor
michael clark their security and defense
analyst asking your questions about the
war in ukraine